the white house announced that the country will not
meet president bailén's goal
of administering at least one dose of
the cob vaccine to 19 to 70
percent of adults even so the
white house says there is good news
sixteen states to 16  states and the
district of colombia if they have reached the
goal of the president and at the national level
70% of adults over 30 years of age
have also received at least one
dose of the vaccine and it is expected that
after the independence holiday weekend they will
also  the goal will be reached
in the population of people
over 27 years of age the biggest challenge now is to
convince young people under 26
years of age to get vaccinated this is an
especially important priority now that
the cobi 19 delta variant is
spreading around the world and  in the usa
greider doctor anthony fauci says that
the delta variant is more contagious and
more dangerous
it is also impacting more children and
adolescents and even causing more
hospitali  zations in this group the good
news is that the vaccines have
proven to be effective against the
delta variant that is why the
government and doctors encourage
all people over the age of 12 to
get vaccinated reporting in washington
alexandra limón